bienvenue donc au sénat et on va vous
donner tout de suite la parole pour la
présentation de votre apport soit en
particulier sur l'année 2020 et puis
sans doute que les questions qui
pourraient arriver au cours de la
discussion
et vous avez donc la parole automatique
pardon excusez moi monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs donc
on a rendu public il ya quelques jours
le rapport d'activité du défenseur des
droits pour l'année 2020 et je suis
vraiment très heureuse de pouvoir vous
le présentez aujourd'hui rencontre de
l'année 2020 c'est d'abord rendre compte
d'une année de transition avant de
présenter l'activité de cette année je
voudrais d'ailleurs rendre hommage à mon
prédécesseur par sa détermination son
engagement jacques toubon a fait
progresser considérablement la notoriété
et la visibilité du défenseur des droits
dans tes contexte troublé il a tenu des
positions courageuses fidèle aux
missions qui lui étaient confiées alors
c'est donc à la tête d'une institution
solide que je suis arrivé en juillet
dernier s'est entouré d'adjoints tout
aussi solide que je m'efforce depuis ma
nomination de continuer à faire jouer
pleinement à cette belle institution le
rôle qui lui est confiée mes adjoints
sont alors à ma droite justement pauline
caby qui est en charge de la déontologie
de la sécurité à ma gauche éric
delamarre qui est en charge de la
défense et la promotion des droits de
l'enfant et qui ne sont pas la cause du
respect des règles sanitaires autrement
nous serons vieux nous serions venus
plus nombreux george pau langevin en
charge de la lutte contre les
discriminations et de la promotion de
l'égalité et daniel agacinski qui est en
charge de la médiation avec les services
publics
alors pour dresser le bilan de l'année
2020 j'évoquerai successivement les
interventions du défenseur des droits
dans quatre directions des interventions
pour répondre aux difficultés nouvelles
créées par la crise sanitaire d
intervention pour traiter au quotidien
les problèmes d'accès au droit pour
promouvoir les droits et défendre les
libertés et quatrièmement pour renforcer
la coopération avec nos homologues
étrangers à leur premier point la crise
sanitaire elle a affecté au delà de nos
modes de vie l'ensemble de nos droits et
libertés
en bouleversant l'organisation des
services publics les mesures sanitaires
se sont souvent traduites par un recul
des droits par de nouveaux obstacles
pour y accéder et pour celles et ceux
qui sont des joies déjà éloignés de
leurs droits ce recul a pu créer de
véritables ruptures
c'est pourquoi dès le début de la crise
sanitaire le défenseur des droits a été
très attentif aux atteintes aux droits
qu'ils étaient susceptibles d'émerger en
particulier pour les personnes les plus
vulnérables au titre de ses différentes
compétences il est intervenu pour y
remédier que ce soit d'ailleurs à
travers les services instructeurs du
siège ou par l'intervention des délégués
territoriaux et je reviendrai d'ailleurs
sûr c'est le rôle de ces délégués
territoriaux
s'agissant des relations avec les
services publics l'institution a été
alertée d'atteinte importante aux droits
et libertés concernant en particulier au
moment du premier confinement les
personnes précaires et vulnérables qui
était contrainte de retirer leurs aides
sociales dans les bureaux de poste
alerté par le défenseur des droits le
directeur de la poste s'est engagée à
augmenter le nombre de bureaux de poste
ouvert
nous avons été également alerter sur la
situation des personnes en détention
pour des motifs liés majoritairement aux
conditions de détention c'est à dire
accès au masque j'ai l'hydraulique accès
aux soins à la douche conditions
d'aménagements de peine d'exécution des
peines suspension des parloirs en
détention usages de la téléphonie
rupture du paiement de travail est
également violences entre détenus et
également pour des motifs dus à la
prolongation de plein droit de la
détention provisoire sans intervention
du juge judiciaire
son contrôle vous savez a finalement été
rétabli par des arrêts adopté en mai par
la cour de cassation pour pallier
l'absence de délégués en établissement
pénitentiaire un numéro de téléphone
dédié a été créé près de 5000 appels ont
été reçus par ce biais c'était
essentiellement pendant le premier
confinement puisqu'après nos délégués
ont pu retourner en dans les centres de
détention les personnes en rétention
administrative qui se sont trouvés dans
des conditions de protection
insuffisante sans perspective
d'éloignement dans un délai raisonnable
et malgré nos demandes de fermeture
immédiate les crasses sont restés
partiellement ouvert les personnes
également en
demande d'asile qui se sont heurtés à la
fermeture du dispositif d'enregistrement
des demandes d'asile est à l'arrêt du
fonctionnement de la plateforme
téléphonique de l'ofii les observations
que nous avons adressé au conseil d'état
saisi d'une requête ont été accueillis
d'ailleurs favorablement et enfin les
personnes bénéficiant de protection
sociale dont les ressources sont parfois
substantiellement baissé
le défenseur des droits est intervenu
pour que leur situation soit prise en
compte en cas de recouvrement des indus
ça c'était la première partie sur les
relations avec les services publics
s'agissant des droits des enfants nous
avons reçu je vous parle toujours de la
période covin plus de 120 saisine
révélant que nombre de ces droits
étaient mises à mal en particulier le
droit d'être protégé contre toutes les
formes de violence le droit d'être
entendu alors que l' ordonnance du 25
mars permettait de prendre des décisions
sans contradictoires le droit
d'entretenir des relations avec ses
parents quand les droits de visite et
d'hébergement été suspendue le droit
d'aller à l'école
le droit de recevoir une protection et
des soins notamment pour des mineurs non
accompagnés ni prise en charge ni
accueilli le droit de voir son intérêt
supérieur prise en compte quand des
enfants entre autres se sont vu refuser
l'accès à un supermarché avec leurs
parents c'était au tout début du premier
confinement s'agissant de la déontologie
de la sécurité les saisines reçues ont
porté essentiellement sur des contrôles
d'attestation de déplacement est par
ailleurs le défenseur des droits s'est
saisi de la situation des personnes sans
domicile fixe et des difficultés
rencontrées par les personnes
handicapées justement à fournir
l'attestation quand c'était nécessaire
enfin de nombreux saisines ont porté sur
des situations de discrimination liée à
la crise sanitaire et à titre d'exemple
je citerai deux situations l'accès aux
biens et services des personnes âgées
des personnes particulièrement
vulnérables économiquement ou
bénéficiant d'une mesure de protection
judiciaire
celles ci ont pu rencontrer des
difficultés s'apparentant à des
discriminations indirectes à travers par
exemple les refus de paiement en espèces
atteinte au sujet de laquelle le réseau
s'est particulièrement mobilisé puisque
ce sont ce genre de choses qui nous sont
remontés directement par par les
délégués et enfin deuxième exemple les
nombreuses restrictions ayant affecté
les résidents des ehpad susceptibles de
porter une atteinte disproportionnée à
leur droit et au respect du mât
tiens des liens familiaux et sociaux les
préconisations formulées au début du
confinement reste d'actualité en
particulier la nécessité que les mesures
prises à l'écart des ehpad soit fondée
sur un principe de prévention
individuelle plutôt que sur un principe
de précaution général le deuxième point
sur lequel je voulais insister
maintenant c'est le travail mené au
quotidien pour faire valoir les droits
des personnes qui nous saisissent avant
dilution ce travail par quelques
exemples il me paraît utile de rappeler
que le défenseur des droits est
constitué d'une double composante le
siège et le réseau des délégués
territoriaux
la présence de ces délégués dans chaque
département auprès des réclamants au
contact des dysfonctionnements et des
atteintes au droit est souvent
déterminante pour répondre au mieux à
chaque situation
dans un contexte de recul les services
publics dans la crise sanitaire a mis en
évidence les graves conséquences
les délégués comble un manque dont les
petites villes et les zones rurales
souffrent de plus en plus la présence
réelle incarner des voies d'accès au
droit
concrètement les 536 délégués qui traite
près de 80 % des réclamations sont eux à
l'origine de la plupart des médiation
conduite par l'institution qui dans 80%
des cas aboutissent favorablement en
cherchant à faire aboutir un règlement
amiable
ce réseau de médiateurs contribuer à
rétablir le dialogue entre les usagers
et l'administration ou les organismes
chargés d'une mission de service public
ce réseau est une force et une
composante précieuse de notre
institution pour l'affermir un nouveau
maillon de coordination et
d'articulation avec le siège a été
introduit ce maillon ce sont douze chefs
de pôles régionaux dans la prise de
fonction s'est achevée en 2020 qui
l'incarnent
il apporte un appui juridique aux
délégués coordonne au niveau régional le
traitement des dossiers
les actions de promotion de l'égalité
les initiatives permettant de faire
progresser la notoriété de l'institution
j'en viens maintenant au traitement des
réclamations en tant que tel en 2020 le
nombre de saisines reçues s'est élevé à
près de 97 milles dont près des deux
tiers
concerne les relations avec les services
publics j'insiste beaucoup là-dessus
près des deux tiers des réclamations qui
nous sont soumises concerne les
relations avec les services publics les
réponses apportées aux situations
individuelles vise à la fois bien sûr le
rétablissement des droits des personnes
qui nous saisissent mais aussi ce second
point est important la résolution des
problèmes structurels pour que les
atteintes constatées ne se répète plus
car très souvent en fait les saisines
reçues révèlent des problèmes qui
dépassent largement l'échelle
individuelle en matière de services
publics les situations dont nous sommes
saisis met en évidence l'ampleur des
délais de réponse des administrations
près de deux ans par exemple pour une
demande de changement non plus de deux
ans pour une réponse d'ailleurs positive
ou négative à une demande de
naturalisation
pour l'illustrer je vais prendre deux
exemples d'abord le cas du forfait post
stationnement de nombreuses saisines ont
fait tant de dysfonctionnements
importants notamment des délivrances de
forfaits de postes stationnement indus à
des personnes qui étaient titulaires
d'une carte de mobilité réduite et des
retards deuxièmement dans le traitement
des recours administratif préalable
obligatoire entraînant des conséquences
financières lourdes
le défenseur des droits a formulé des
recommandations envers les collectivités
territoriales afin que les usagers
puissent être rétablis dans leurs droits
dans un rapport publié en janvier 2020
il a préconisé notamment une meilleure
information sur les modalités de
stationnement et les tarifs
une meilleure formation des agents
chargés de traiter les recours gracieux
et l'exonération de paiement préalable à
la saisine de la commission du
contentieux du stationnement payant pour
les personnes victimes de vols ou d'
usurpation de plaque d'immatriculation
ou de cession de véhicules
le conseil constitutionnel saisi d'une
question prioritaire de
constitutionnalité sur ce sujet a
d'ailleurs jugé inconstitutionnelle la
condition de paiement préalable à la
saisine de cette commission
le deuxième exemple que je voulais vous
donner c'est le traitement des
discriminations offre donc un deuxième
exemple de la manière dont le défenseur
des droits entend apporter aux
situations dont il est saisi des
réponses non seulement à 10
elle mais aussi structurelles les
réclamations dont nous sommes saisis en
matière de discrimination nous révèle
qu'elle revête parfois qu'elles revêtent
parfois un caractère systémique elle ne
résulte pas seulement d'actes
individuels
elles sont aussi le produit d'inégalités
collective de représentation de préjugés
et d'assignation qui traverse toute la
société
c'est pourquoi dans un rapport publié en
juin dernier le défenseur des droits a
formulé un certain nombre de
recommandations pour aller au delà de la
simple résolution de situations
individuelles genre le vrai 3
approfondir d'abord la connaissance des
discriminations en développant des
statistiques publiques en créant entre
autres un observatoire des
discriminations mais en développant
aussi des campagnes de testing
deuxièmement développer une politique
ambitieuse en réalisant des audits
réguliers au sein des organisations
en renforçant les obligations et aussi
les sanctions
et troisièmement améliorer le traitement
judiciaire des discriminations rendant
plus effectives l'action de groupe et en
appliquant des sanctions proportionnées
et réellement dissuasives pour rendre
plus visibles nos compétences en matière
de lutte contre les discriminations et
améliorer l'accompagnement des victimes
nous avons par ailleurs mis en place un
nouvel outil grâce à des moyens humains
et financiers renforcés vous en avez
probablement entendu déjà parlé et pris
connaissance il s'agit de la plate forme
anti discrimination point fr qui a été
lancé le 12 février dernier à la demande
du président de la république
conçue et piloter en toute indépendance
par le défenseur des droits ce nouveau
service de signalement et
d'accompagnement fonctionne de la
manière suivante toutes victimes ou
témoins de discriminations quel qu'en
soit le motif et le domaine peut
solliciter la plateforme soit en
appelant le 39 28 soit en se rendant sur
le site internet qui est doté d'un chat
et d'un accès spécifique pour les
personnes sourdes ou malentendantes
hélas une équipe de juristes du
défenseur des droits accompagne oriente
gratuitement les personnes qui
sollicitent la plateforme
je pourrais d'ailleurs vous proposer
tout à l'heure si vous le souhaitez un
bilan du premier mois de fonctionnement
de cette plate forme avec quelques
premiers chiffres le troisième point que
je voulais aborder avec vous c'est qu'au
delà du traitement des réclamations le
défenseur des droits a confirmé tout au
long de l'année 2020 son rôle de vigie
des droits et des libertés
cette vigilance qui se nourrit
des saisines reçues et des constats
transmis par les associations membres de
nos comité d'entente m'a conduit à
formuler régulièrement des alertes sur
les différents projets et propositions
de loi présentées je les fais par
exemple à propos du nouveau schéma de
maintien de l'ordre de la réforme de la
justice pénale des mineurs de la
transposition de la directive relative
aux lanceurs d'alert de la réforme de
l'adoption par exemple s'agissant plus
particulièrement des mesures prises dans
le cadre de l'état d'urgence sanitaire
dans la lignée de nos prédécesseurs je
me suis attaché à rappeler un certain
nombre d'exigences de notre état de
droit auquel il ne saurait être dérogé
et je sais que vous y êtes très attaché
à l'occasion de plusieurs auditions et
avis transmis au parlement j'ai ainsi
souligné l'importance d'encadrer
strictement l'état d'urgence par une loi
précise claire prévisible intelligible
dans le respect des principes de
l'égalité de nécessité et de
proportionnalité de veiller à ce qu'ils
restent exceptionnels en limitant sa
durée et en prévoyant des moyens de
droit commun pour un retour à la
normalité de renforcer le rôle du
parlement d'organiser un débat public de
fonds en particulier sur la protection
de nos droits et libertés le
renforcement des services publics et
enfin de renforcer la transparence et
l'accessibilité de l'information
plus généralement il m'a paru essentiel
à travers ses différentes alertes de
mettre en garde contre le risque d' une
habituation progressive à la restriction
de nos libertés
à l'heure où vivre avec le virus ne
relève plus d'une option mais bien d'une
nécessité
le choix que nous faisons pour
l'affronter doivent faire l'objet de
discussion libre et éclairé je
terminerai par katrian quatrième point
en évoquant la dimension internationale
de nos actions sur ses différents champs
de compétence le défenseur des droits
poursuivis et approfondis tout au long
de l'année 2020 le travail de
collaboration avec nos homologues
internationaux en matière de déontologie
de la sécurité de réalisation souligner
cette coopération d'une part l'adoption
en juin 2020 de la déclaration de paris
par le réseau a aidé cannes independence
police complet authorities network
elle reprend les principales
recommandations issues de la conférence
qui avait été réalisée en octobre 2000
neuf sur les relations police population
et d'autre part la célébration en
octobre des 20 ans de la recommandation
du conseil de l'europe sur le code
d'éthique de la police et cette
célébration a été l'occasion d'échangés
très riche avec nos homologues mais
aussi avec les hauts représentants des
ministres de l'intérieur du conseil de
l'europe en matière de défense et de
promotion des droits de l'enfant le
défenseur des droits s'est associé à la
réflexion du réseau enoch qui est un
réseau européen des défenseurs des
enfants
à propos des études d'impact sur les
droits des enfants un cadre commun de
référence a été adoptée afin
d'harmoniser ses études dans l'objectif
est d'anticiper les effets de toute
mesure sur les droits des enfants
le thème du rapport annuel sur les
droits de l'enfant s'inscrivait
pleinement dans cette thématique
puisqu'il portait sur la prise en compte
de la parole de l'enfant une composante
centrale des études d'impact sur le
droit des enfants
s'agissant de la lutte contre les
discriminations le défenseur des droits
poursuivi ses travaux au sein du réseau
européen des organismes de promotion de
l'égalité et queen est dont il est
membre élu au conseil d'administration
le défenseur des droits a activement
contribué aux initiatives portées par ce
réseau à travers notamment un rapport
sur l'inclusion des roms et des gens du
voyage des publications sur les effets
discriminatoires du recours au numérique
et à l'intelligence artificielle en
période pandémique pour l'accès au droit
et pour l'emploi des plus vulnérables et
enfin s'agissant de la protection des
lanceurs d'alert le défenseur des droits
a poursuivi son implication dans le
réseau des autorités européennes en
charge des lanceurs d'un d'alert nehoua
en particulier les deux séminaires
organisés dans la perspective de la
transposition de la directive européenne
sur la protection des personnes qui
signalent des violations au droit de
l'union permis d'aboutir à des
recommandations communes pour d'abord
améliorer la lisibilité des dispositifs
nationaux et renforcer les droits des
lanceurs d'alerté
je conclurai brièvement en insistant sur
le point suivant ce rapport d'activité
confirme à quel point le défenseur des
droits constitue un recours crucial pour
toutes celles et ceux qui ne parviennent
pas à exercer leurs droits
il nous rappelle que le droit s'il est
bien le socle de notre démocratie n'est
rien sans les moyens mis en oeuvre pour
le faire respecter
et en tant que défenseur des droits ma
mission est précisément de faire en
sorte que tous ceux qui en sont
éloignées soient rétablis dans leurs
droits
c'est un des éléments essentiels de la
confiance dans notre démocratie jour
merci et je suis prête à répondre à vos
questions
la présidente et bien écoutez oui nous
allons débuter une série de questions
monsieur dany wattebled a souhaité vous
poser une question
non
un petit peu un petit peu fort de faire
des différences entre de différents
secteurs et mes questions papa tu étais
vont être direct vous pouvez vous nous
confirmer par rapport aux propos du
premier ministre si vous ne pousserait
pas la création de non contrôle et je
considère pour ma part que les forces de
l'ordre sont garantes de la sécurité des
gâtés de tous les français devant
l'album et pouvait nous faire part de
votre point de vue par ailleurs on
constate sans soins mais aussi également
victimes d'attaqués injustifiées qu'elle
soutient comptez vous leur portez merci
monsieur météo les monsieur françois
bonhomme
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente
d'abord je me suis efforcé de lire votre
rapport avec avec beaucoup d'intérêt
d'abord alors je sais votre rapport mais
vous avez pris vos fonctions au mois de
juillet donc je ne sais pas comment dans
quelles mesures vous revendiquez ou tel
ou tel parti
enfin je pense que de par les fonctions
vous sera même de répondre à l'ensemble
des questions j'ai quelques questions
alors non pas sur ce que vous avez
évoquées mais sur ce qui vous ne votez
pas forcément d'ailleurs qui pourrait
peut-être rentrer dans prochain de
compétences d'abord j'aimerais que vous
me donnez l'occasion vous donner
l'occasion de préciser ce que vous
n'aviez ou pas dit concernant les zones
de non-droit des couffins plutôt les
zones où que vous envisagez
d'expérimenter sans contrôle d'identité
vous avez indiqué devant la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale que
vos propos était déformé ou mal compris
or si j'en juge de votre interview votre
c'est que la recension qui n'a été fait
en france info j'ai bien noté qu'il
s'agissait effectivement effectivement
d'expérimenter des zones sans contrôle
d'identité donc j'aimerais que vous
expliquer à nouveau là tu clairement sur
ce que vous entendez par là le cas
échéant est ce cette intervention venait
à propos des contrôles d'identité et
d'autres interventions laissant entendre
qu' il ya un continuum je veux dire de
sur votre analyse parce que vous dites
que les contrôles d'identité si j'ai
bien compris ne servent à rien pour
l'essentiel là aussi peut être vous
aurez l'occasion de préciser mais
j'aimerais savoir comment vous resituer
dans ce que l'action de la police qui
évoluent dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles qui sont régulièrement
agressés qui sont régulièrement prises à
partie où l'objet de tirs de mortiers
commun trappe dernièrement qu'ils sont
obligés de menace permanente et pourtant
et vous même vous y participer ils sont
formés de manière régulière pour agir
dans des conditions de plus en plus
difficile j'aimerais savoir comment vous
considérez avec ce ce pouvoir
d'appréciation qu'on doit me semble-t-il
est laissée aux forces de police pour
juger de l'opportunité ou non d'user de
son droit de contrôler les identités des
personnes sur la voie publique
ça c'est une première chose la deuxième
chose que j'aimerais sur lequel
j'aimerais vous interrogez c'est sûr
l'unef
l'unef a eu des propos par la voix de sa
présidence tout à fait étonnant
puisqu'elle reconnaît sans difficulté
d'ailleurs l'organisation de réunions de
non mixtes donc en gros
enfin pas en gros en clair
l'organisme de réunion selon l'origine
la couleur de la peau selon l'origine
des participants il me semble acquis un
élément assez caractérisée de ce qui
relèverait d'une discrimination
donc j'aimerais savoir sauf erreur de ma
part vous n'êtes pas fait déclarations
publiques ou de communiqués de presse
dans ce sens c'est ce que vous entendez
intervenir dans la discussion le cas
échéant usez de votre pouvoir
d'auto-saisine est le cas dans le cas
contraire pourquoi vous considéreriez si
c'était pas le cas que ça ne justifie
pas de votre cas de vos deux auto saisir
de cette discussion
voilà et puis dans votre rapport que je
vais beaucoup d'intérêt toujours à la
page concernant les discriminations
vous évoquez la situation de jeunes qui
en 2020 se sont ont été accompagnés de
dire devant le tribunal judiciaire
dix sept jeunes gens qui auraient qui
ont sont allés devant les tribunaux
judiciaires pour discrimination
discriminatoires lors de contrôles
d'identité et voici ce que vous dites
puisque ces observations ont porté sur
l'analyse des situations faisant l'objet
du recours sur la base de faits
résultant de l'enquète du tribunal
judiciaire et du dossier il a relevé
qu'en l'espèce le contexte d instruction
représailles entourant ces
discriminations avait un caractère
systémique dans un contexte à de
répétition des violations de procédure
alors vous avez émis effectivement des
observations si j'ai bien compris et
vous vous même vous indiquez c'est tout
à votre honneur que le jugement du 28
octobre qui s'en est suivi a établi que
le tribunal a considéré que la preuve
d'une différenciation de différence de
traitement n'était pas rapportée par les
demandeurs donc ça confirme ça peut
confirmer en tout cas des situations
vous êtes amené à prendre des positions
à faire des analyses et que des
tribunaux viennent ne pas vous suivre
sur ce terrain là donc j'aimerais savoir
si vous en lequel des chiens si ça vous
amène à en tout cas le défenseur des
droits à faire preuve d'une plus grande
mesure dans les propos et dans les
analyses
parce que le principal point pour moi
deux de réserve que j'ai à faire c'est
que on n'est plus dans dénonciation
termes que vous utilisez à certains
endroits du rapport que dans l'analyse
et je trouve que l'institution que vous
représentez que vous présidez aurait
vraiment avantage à faire un peu plus d'
analyse et impôts même dénonciation
simun valérie boyer et vous savez le mot
je vous en prie
ça peut arriver madame la défenseur des
droits je voulais aller probablement dit
tout à l'heure mais moi je me permettrai
avant de commencer de saluer votre
parcours
puisque vous êtes ancien journaliste
santé à rfi président d'atd quart monde
et membre du comité consultatif national
d'éthique
c'est un parcours magnifique mais sans
remettre en cause vos compétences et
votre parcours j'aimerais revenir sur un
point
c'est vrai que j'aurais pu vous parler
de beaucoup de choses comme mon collègue
françois bonhomme vient de le faire
longuement vos alertes sur la fermeture
des guichets pour les demandeurs d'asile
ou de mineurs non accompagnés et vous
êtes dans votre rôle de défenseur des
droits
mais je crois aussi que lorsque nous
parlons immigration et droit des
étrangers on peut aussi parler des
devoirs et je voudrais aussi évoqué
cette question en disant une chose est
ce faire preuve d'humanité que de donner
de faux espoirs à des personnes qui fuit
leur pays
est-ce faire preuve d'humanité que de
faire en sorte que ses enfants
pour beaucoup d'entre eux soit aux
victimes de trafic d'êtres humains est
jeté sur les routes en ile-de-france en
alsace en provence aux côtes enfin en
provence alpes côte d'azur à marseille
en particulier nos capacités d'accueil
vous le savez sont saturés nos capacités
d'accueil sont tellement saturé que
parfois l'accueil se fait au détriment
des enfants de la ze dans des conditions
qui sont parfois extrêmement difficile
je ne reviendrais même pas sur la
question défauts mineurs
cela se constate de manière en matière
de logement mais on le voit aussi
beaucoup dans la rue et s faire preuve
de raison que de ne pas lutter
efficacement contre ces trafics d'êtres
humains mais j'aimerais évoquer avec
vous un point particulier aux moitié
vrillé vous avez suscité la polémique en
proposant d'expérimenter des zones sans
contrôle d'identité pour lutter contre
les discriminations
je dois vous avouer que cette prise de
position m'a profondément choqué car je
crois que la république doit regagner
ses quartiers et non totalement
disparaître
je crois au dialogue mais je crois aussi
à l'ordre et au respect des valeurs de
la république sur l'ensemble du
territoire national sans exception et je
considère qu'il ne peut y avoir en
france des zones de
endroit même si je préfère parler des
zones d'un autre droit et celui de la
voyoucratie en particulier depuis que
vous avez préciser vos propos en
indiquant souhaiter une meilleure
traçabilité de ces opérations
bien sûr mais vos propos s'inscrivent
dans un contexte de tensions importantes
avec des forces de l'ordre les forces de
l'ordre qui sont régulièrement
d'ailleurs elle-même victime d'attaqués
régulières de keita pan etc
je vais pas revenir sur les chiffres de
d'atteinte aux forces de l'ordre et le
nombre de blessés des forces de l'ordre
mais ils sont quand même très élevé
le chef de l'état avait par exemple
considérer qu'aujourd'hui quand on a une
couleur de peau qui n'est pas blanche
on est beaucoup plus contrôlés il est
vrai qu'en france je le cite ans entre
guillemets il est vrai qu'en france le
sujet des contrôles d'identité est un
sujet sensible
c'est dans ces conditions qu'il a été
annoncé que sur certains territoires il
sera prévu des dispositifs d'évaluation
de l'efficacité de ces contrôles grâce à
des caméras d'une application spécifique
pour compter le nombre de contrôles
leurs lieux et leurs résultats ou encore
via la délivrance d'un récépissé
aussi j'aimerais vous poser une question
que proposez vous pour les forces de
l'ordre les pompiers les personnels
soignants pour qu'ils puissent enfin
exercer leur métier sereinement dans ces
quartiers pour confiant pour qu'enfin
pour qu'enfin excusez moi ils arrivent
ils arrêtent
excusez moi le masque que c'est
compliqué ils arrêtent d'être pris pour
cible pour qu'enfin on des fonds de
leurs droits et aussi qu'on les protège
parce que vous n'ignorez pas non plus
que par rapport au droit et notamment
leur famille les situations sont
extrêmement complexes
on l'a on l'a abordée dans le texte sur
la sécurité globale qui a été examinée
au parlement mais j'aurais bien aimé
vous entendre sur
sur ces sur la défense des droits de ces
personnes
je vous remercie merci alain boyer il ya
d'autres questions
oui monsieur jean pierre sueur dans la
suite de ma collègue je voulais savoir
quelle est votre réaction par rapport à
la déclaration récente du ministre de
l'intérieur qui a dit qu'il fallait
expulser par la force les enfants
mineurs et éventuellement non
accompagnés qui était en centre de
détention
alors je crois que le droit ne permet
pas d'expulser des mineurs donc
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
déclaration est est ce que vous avez
l'intention de réagir par rapport à cela
peut-être l'avez-vous déjà fait si
monsieur sur d'autres questions
moi j'en ai peut-être une madame la
présidente à la défense excusez moi
c'est parce que pareil que président
votre désignation est récente
ainsi que celles d'ailleurs de du
contrôleur général des lieux de
privation de liberté
ma question porte à peu sur relations
entre les deux institutions et entre
vous parlez relations personnelles qui
n'ont aucune importance notamment
mais les relations skipper quand
monsieur mouche mais sur les compétences
et sur l'exercice des recommandations
des contrôles que vous pouvez faire donc
ce ne serait utile de bien comprendre le
mécanisme de fonctionnement entre les
deux institutions qui vont être
maintenant à votre de votre
responsabilité et de celle de contrôleur
général des produits de privation de
liberté
et monsieur kerrouche qui se manifestent
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente peut-être parce que votre
rapport est important notamment sur la
thématique des discriminations je
voudrais pas que certaines prises de
paroles laisse penser que celle-ci
n'existe pas
peut-être vous pourriez nous retracer un
tableau aussi des discriminations qui
existent de la façon dont elles sont
quantifiés et aussi donc de la
perspective selon laquelle on pourrait
lutter contre lutter contre celle-ci
bien y'a pas d'autres questions
enfin sur vous avez la parole vous avez
la défenseure merci je vais je vais
procéder à priori dans l'ordre je
comprends alors je vais démarrer sur la
question des contrôles d'identité je
comprends tout à fait votre question
cette audition est aussi l'occasion pour
moi d'affiner d'affiner mes propos la
protection est avant toute chose je
tiens à le dire la protection des
policiers des gendarmes est un objectif
plus que légitime c'est un principe
auxquels je suis très attaché
ce que j'ai dit sur les contrôles
d'identité ont pu être déformés même si
je reconnais quelques imprécisions dans
la façon de le dire je n'ai jamais
souhaité mettre fin au contrôle
d'identité
je souhaite la traçabilité ces contrôles
sont indispensables en cas de
comportement suspect de risque à l'ordre
public ou bien sur réquisition du
procureur de la république
la population doit être protégé avec un
maintien de la présence de la police et
je vous redis que je suis consciente des
difficultés dans laquelle intervient
interviennent les policiers pour exercer
leurs missions
mais l'arrêt de la cour de cassation de
2016 a acté l'existence de contrôles
discriminatoires
le contrôle de l'identité doit être
motivée mais en fait on n'a pas de
traçabilité donc c'est impossible de
savoir si c'est motivé il ya pour moi
une nécessité d'évaluation aujourd'hui
nous ne savons pas combien de contrôles
sont effectués à quel endroit à quelle
heure pour quel motif et pour quel
résultat
je n'ai jamais dit qu'ils étaient
toujours inutile loin de moi cette idée
mais nous ne savons pas aujourd'hui en
france si nous avons 5 8 ou 12 millions
de contrôles d'identité par an et je
pense qu'une évaluation serait
intéressante ce que j'ai toujours dit
c'est que je pense
une expérimentation serait nécessaire
sur cette question de la traçabilité et
quand je dis une expérimentation c'est
que je ne sais pas quelle est la
meilleure solution
est ce que c'est le récépissé est-ce que
c'est simplement une expérimentation
avec l'enregistrement mais sans
récépissé mais qui permet aux personnes
qui se sentent victimes de contrôle
d'identité discriminatoires de faire un
recours est ce que c'est comme vous
l'avez dit la caméra piétons il y a
plusieurs possibilités et je pense qu'il
faut l'expérimenter
vous savez qu'un député a déposé une
proposition de loi sur cette question
des contrôles d'identité avec récépissé
sachez qu'au moment où on a préparé on
devait être auditionné puis finalement
ça n'a pas été possible
sur les dix dernières années il y a eu
douze propositions de loi sur cette
question des contrôles d'identité est ce
que je dit juste c'est qu'on est face à
un problème et qu'il faudrait le
résoudre et dans cette question là il ne
s'agit pas d'accuser personne mais
d'essayer de trouver une solution
donc je j'ai tout à fait conscience des
tensions avec les forces de l'ordre et
je pense que c'est par de la
transparence qu'on pourra conforter et
rétablir la confiance et je pense que
cette confiance elle est indispensable à
notre à notre démocratie
dans les autres questions que vous même
que vous m'avez posé sur l'unef
il est évident pour moi que pour une
réunion publique
on ne peut pas utiliser un critère
discriminatoire
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus après je
ne souhaite pas entrer dans les
polémiques et je trouve que les
polémiques se multiplient mais je vous
redis que la notre position là dessus
pour une réunion publique
on ne peut pas utiliser un critère
discriminatoire sur la question du droit
des étrangers et des mineurs non
accompagnés
ce que nous constatons et je suis dans
mon rôle en tant que défenseur des
droits cédés des atteintes aux droits
fondamentaux des atteintes à la question
de l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant
et je ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait de
concurrence entre les personnes
précaires se préoccuper des droits
fondamentaux des étrangers c'est une
question dans lequel il ya des atteintes
à la dignité c'est une question de
dignité
et c'est la même chose sur la question
des personnes les plus précaires et vu
mon engagement précédemment je pense que
vous ne pouvez pas douter de mon
engagement sur ces questions là et sur
la question de la défense des droits
fondamentaux que nous parlions
d'étrangers ou de situations de
personnes précaires en france je vous
redis pas de concurrence entre les
personnes en difficulté je ne pense pas
que ce soit la façon de résoudre cette
question je suis comme vous très
inquiète
la question du trafic d'êtres humains je
partage complètement votre votre votre
inquiétude mais je vous redis la
question du respect et de et des
atteintes pour le coup des droits
fondamentaux que l'on voit sur ces
populations étrangères a su ces mineurs
non accompagnés me paraît me paraît
inquiétante et je suis comme vous aussi
inquiètes dont je vous le dis sur c'est
sur ces trafics d'êtres humains sur sur
l'expulsion de mineurs
oui toujours
la situation d'un certain nombre de
mineurs qui sont en citant entre autres
en situation de santé très difficile
avec des poly addiction est
excessivement est excessivement
compliqué je la solution n'est
absolument pas simple mais je ne pense
pas qu'il faille non plus raisonner en
terme sur l'ensemble des mineurs non
accompagnés qui sont dans cette
situation là mais nous sommes confrontés
à des mineurs non accompagnés qui
viennent entre autres d'algérie et du
maroc et avec de forts problème avec de
graves problèmes de dépendance sur la
question je sais pas si répondu à tout y
est mieux j'arrive pas à me relire sur
ce que j'ai noté sur une des questions
sur la sur les discriminations je peux
je peux vous dire un mot sur sur la
plateforme au bout d'un mois de
fonctionnement on a eu à peu près onze
mille contacts là-dessus 3000 personnes
qui nous ont appelés donc le numéro de
téléphone le 39,28 emile chat les mots
là-dessus simplement 20% nous ont
finalement saisi ce qui veut dire
plusieurs choses c'est qu'il ya des gens
qui nous ont appelés pour des questions
par exemple de sexisme le racisme qui ne
sont pas dans notre domaine ou de
violences et on a renvoyé sur les
services de l'état ou sur les
associations sur ces questions et puis
un certain nombre ce que nous disent nos
écoutant qui sont des juristes dit un
certain nombre avaient besoin d'être
écoutés mais ne se sentait pas forcément
d'attac de déposer pour autant une '
réclamations donc pour l'instant les
chiffres qu'on a c'est 20% de
réclamation c'est un peu tôt pour vous
donner les résultats que qu'on peut
avoir les le domaine reste l'emploi on
n'est pas très étonné c'est le premier
motif d'appel sur les questions de
discriminations et
l'origine est le premier des critères
alors que dans les réclamations que nous
avons sur les 5000 réservations que nous
avons tous les ans c'est plutôt la
question du handicap qui arrive en tête
des discriminations et on a un public un
peu plus jeune qui du coup nous
contacter via via la via la plateforme
sur de façon plus générale la lutte
contre les discriminations en fait on a
du mal à évaluer l'ampleur de ces
discriminations c'est quand même une des
grosses difficultés et c'est pour ça
qu'on préconise la création d'un
observatoire qui permet tier permettrait
de mieux évaluer ces discriminations et
du coup de mieux de mieux y répondre
et cette plateforme elle va être un
outil pour résoudre au quotidien les
problèmes des personnes a
majoritairement d'ailleurs par la
médiation parce que dans les saisines
qu'on a eue il ya eu des choses très
très simple de aménagement d'un poste de
travail pour une personne handicapée
c'est assez facile derrière d'appeler
l'employeur de lui dire qu'il a une
obligation et et la question peut être
résolu relativement relativement
rapidement
je suis assez frappé d'ailleurs depuis
que je suis arrivé dans l'institution du
nombre de saisines que nous avons plus
tellement maintenant sur l'accueil des
enfants à l'école où on a progressé même
si c'est loin d'être parfait mais on a
quand même progressé mais plutôt sur
l'accueil d'enfants handicapés dans des
centres de loisirs qui reste encore
quelque chose de compliqué donc notre
souci avec la plateforme c'est de
résoudre les problèmes au quotidien des
personnes qui nous saisissent et on le
peut et en partie par la médiation
mais tout ça ne sera pas suffisant et je
pense qu'il faut aussi des campagnes
d'information de sensibilisation à ces
questions à ces questions de
discrimination
le lien avec la contrôleur général des
lieux de privation de liberté bien nous
en l'occurrence eric la rencontrer
aujourd'hui moi je les ai déjà vus deux
fois nous avons des échanges réguliers
où on lui renvoie des affaires quand
c'est plus dans son domaine assez
générales et et nous au contraire quand
c'est des situations particulières
honnêtement la le travail se fait était
très fluide et depuis longtemps fluide
avec cette institution est entre nos
deux institutions
on n'a pas de
de problème particulier tu as peut-être
ajouter quelque chose d'eric sur ce que
sont au rendez vous avec dominique
simonnot un petit bouton au pied du
micro éventuellement merci je voulais
juste rappeler que la france quand même
de manière importante devant le rappeler
a signé dès 1990 a ratifié la convention
internationale des droits de l'enfant de
1989 un de ces quatre grands principes
c'est la non discrimination des enfants
que ce soit dû à leur origine ou leur
couleur le sexe ou la ou leur religion
dans son article 22 le droit des enfants
étrangers lorsqu'ils sont privés
temporairement ou définitivement de
leurs familles de bénéficier de la même
protection tool de tous les enfants et
rappeler également que lorsque les
enfants mineurs non accompagnés sont
confiés à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
nous sommes régulièrement saisi pour des
défauts d'accès à la santé et à
l'éducation qui laisse quand même penser
que ces enfants sont d'abord perçues
comme des étrangers avant d'être perçus
comme des enfants bien même boyer froid
vous avez redemander la parole
là
r ou des pardons ou des difficultés je
crois que personne ne souhaite ça ici
pourtant je trouve que la situation est
absolument dramatique dans les foyers de
la zone qui vous le savez sont
totalement débordés pour plusieurs
raisons une des raisons c'est que l'état
ne remplit pas ses obligations en termes
financièrement cas mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés coûte à peu près 50 mille
euros par an rien que pour l'hébergement
au sein des départements et que on est
confronté au fait qu'on met ses enfants
qui sont parmi les plus fragiles les
plus discriminés ceux qui ont besoin de
plus de protection puisqu'ils sont dans
ses foyers
on les met en contact avec des mineurs
ou des soi disant mineures et là je
voudrais en venir à ça qu'ils ont vécu
des situations extrêmement compliquée
puisqu'ils ont été envoyées en europe
ils ont fait des traversées très
difficile et je pense que celle salim et
dans des situations périlleuses c'est le
premier point le deuxième point au
niveau de la défense des droits de ces
mineurs et au niveau aussi de la défense
des droits des nôtres ces personnes qui
font partie des trafics d'êtres humains
je me permets juste de rappeler que le
trafic d'êtres humains dans le monde ces
32 milliards de dollars c'est ce qui
rapporte peu plus après la drogue et le
trafic d'armes donc c'est pas rien c'est
à une véritable organisation c'est quand
nous avons en france des personnes qui
sont rentrés illégalement qui font
l'objet
de prise en charge par des passeurs et
qui ne veulent pas se soumettre à des
tests ou quand elles se soumettent à des
tests osseux pour qu'on détermine leur
minorité ou leur majorité ne le souhaite
pas moi je trouve que ça crée une
discrimination importante et je pense au
même si on veux pas les mettre en
concurrence mais je pense aux mineurs en
particulier aux mineurs de la zone qui
sont qui sont pris en charge par le
département et on se trouve dans une
situation je trouve qui pour eux n'est
pas tolérable
c est enfin je voudrais conclure vous le
savez également parce que j'imagine que
comme moi comme bien d'autres de mes
collègues vous avez lu dans la presse
même si elle est assez discrète sur ses
histoires
parmi les plus sordides les difficultés
auxquelles sont plus que des difficultés
d'ailleurs les grands malheurs auxquels
sont confrontés parfois ces mineurs puis
ce qu'on appelle c'est souvent ces
mineurs la dent dans ses foyers ou qui
font partie de ce qu'on appelle la
prostitution de citer pour que c'est
comme ça qu'on l'appelle donc qu'ils
sont eux mêmes pris en charge par des
réseaux en france que ce soit des
mineurs j'allais dire en des milk ou
qu'il fasse partie des mineurs étrangers
non accompagnés donc cette question
c'est pas d'opposer les gentils et les
méchants mais c'est de voir comment
sur le plan de la lutte contre les
discriminations comment on protège ceux
qui ont besoin de l'être le plus est
aujourd'hui en ne prenant pas à bras le
corps sur le plan politique et
l'organisation cette question des
mineurs non accompagnés
je trouve que nous ne répondons pas
notre devoir de protection de dos
mineurs les plus fragiles et c'est là
dessus que j'aurais bien aimé qu'on
avance un petit peu sur les
discriminations et sur les atteintes à
leurs droits fondamentaux dont font
partie ses enfants de la zone pourquoi
oui merci monsieur présence juge de
rebondir sur votre réponse madame la
présidente
la défense excusez moi non je sais bien
que vous avez pris vos fonctions il ya
moins de temps donc je veux dire par
rapport aux déclarations qui ont fait
l'objet d'une polémique je suis tout
frais à faire preuve de mansuétude de
clémence je vais dire si tenté que ce
soit possible pour moi mais en attendant
s'il ya un malentendu initiale vous dit
à la fois qu'il faut quantifier qu'il
faut évaluer et maintenant dans les
propos de votre avoir peut-être que sur
votre prédécesseur je ne sais pas mais
vous dénoncer le caractère
discriminatoire et systémique de
contrôle des discriminations en espèces
ce qui me paraît un tout petit peu
contradictoires avant même une
évaluation précise et quantifier de
d'avoir un jugement aussi définitive sur
la question est aussi je vais dire
systématique pour le coup voilà donc
j'écoute bien compris que maintenant
c'est pas vous voulez pas expérimenter
les zones sans contrôle d'entités mais
l'expérimenté la traçabilité
donc j'espère que vous aurez l'occasion
de préciser ce que vous entendez par
france habilités et des formes que ça
peut prendre même si je vous rappelle
mon âme un défenseur que vous dites il
ya douze propositions de loi qui ont été
déposées à ce sujet oui mais il ya eu un
gouvernement précédent même papa sous
son régime j'allais dire qu'ils avaient
ce sujet qui est même été dans une
campagne présidentielle n'est pas si
longtemps que ça et qui a abandonné le
sujet pour tout un tas de raisons qu'on
peut entendre notamment la question
aussi de la difficulté de la mission
encore une fois des forces de police et
notamment l'alourdissement des charges
que s'entraînerait donc il ya quand même
des questions si vous voulez et appuyez
sur l'unef
vous me dites que vous ne souhaite pas
entrer dans les polémiques mais je vois
que dans certains cas vous n'êtes pas
l'origine mais le défenseur droit peut
alimenter des poulies et puis la
polémique se fait partie la démocratie
après tout on ne pas en avoir peur en
attendant défenseur je m'excuse mais
quand on a une déclaration aussi clair
et aussi une transgression aussi
caractérisée de nos principes
fondamentaux avec la déclaration d'un
prétendu l'unef
je suis quand même très étonné en tout
cas au nom du sens comme heures
peut-être commandes d'une autorité
administrative indépendante qui dispose
de toute une armée de juristes
que le sens commun nous amène pas quand
même à user de votre droit de suite de
votre droit d'auto saisine que par
ailleurs quand même vous utilisez
défenseur des droits en général de
manière forte est quasiment systématique
donc je vais te suivrai de la
sélectivité des critères qui président à
votre auto saisine il faudrait quand
même là je pense que je peut invoquer
peut-être le sens commun comme s'il y
avait de telles déclarations que ça ne
traîne pas pour le moins une suite à
travers une saisine je dois dire que les
bras m'en tombent
et j'ai du mal à voir une explication
claire sur le sujet voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire je pense que là
l'intérêt de ce genre de confrontation
c'est d'avoir une certaine sincérité je
tenais quand même hein vous le dire même
si vous êtes un mot de fonction ce que
je peux comprendre par ailleurs par le
mois de débats que de confrontation
même la défense un défenseur pas au vc
st jean n'est d'accord je joue je vous
réponds du coup tout de suite là dessus
en fait en question d'autosaisine c'est
en fait assez peu fréquent on en fait
mais pas du tout énormément et en fait
quand il ya des c donc on est dans des
critères assez précis canton
s'autosaisit c'est sur des situations
gravissime
voilà donc ça c'est la pression est bien
d'aider autosaisine quand il ya eu quand
il ya eu
d un décès dans des violences
de la police voilà c'est un des moments
où on saute aussi donc non on ne
s'autosaisit pas tout le temps et à tour
de bras donc voilà ça reste
attendez je dirige et excusez moi oui
j'ai pas forcément envie d'être je
continue à dire que je n'ai pas envie
d'être dans un débat polémique jeu ce
que je cherche ses affaires oui je suis
bien rires non je jouerai à jeux wii jeu
monsieur le président je suis vraiment
insupportable mais je réagis non
vraiment je réagis parce que voyez-vous
l'unef on est nombreux à avoir milité à
l'unef
non mais dans les temps toi toi tu es
une jeune mais dans les temps anciens où
l'unef fera rassemblé un très grand
nombre d'étudiants et défendez
défendez-le a vraiment les la situation
des étudiants les causes et donc bon on
est triste quand on est dans cette
situation de voir cela et je vous assure
madame la défenseure que je considère
pour ma part que c'est gravissime
le fait que dans la république française
à une mouvement de jeunesse organise des
réunions où il ya les noirs d'un côté
les blancs de l'autre c'est quelque
chose qui est totalement gravissime et
c'est pourquoi je me suis permis de vous
interpeller deux voulaient même de vous
interrompre madame la défenseure et
pardonnez moi je pense que ce serait
justifié qu'il y ait une une déclaration
extrêmement précises comme l'a demandé
monsieur bonhomme de de cette chose qui
est contraire vraiment au vivre ensemble
puis au contraire à la constitution
totalement par excusez moi j'arrête
merci
c'est de votre intervention on redonne
la parole à même la défenseure je vous
je vous redis ce que je viens de dire
est ma déclaration est très solennel
pour une réunion publique
on ne peut pas utiliser un critère
discriminatoire
je vous le redis pour une réunion
publique
on ne peut pas utiliser un critère
discriminatoire je pense que je que je
dis est assez clair jeu sur la question
des contrôles d'identité je vais je vais
du coup laissé la parole à pauline caby
en charge de la déontologie des forces
de sécurité pour poursuivre la réponse
vous redire que en 2016
un arrêt de la cour de cassation a
reconnu l'existence de contrôle
d'identité discriminatoires
je ne fais que redire ce qu'a dit la
cour de cassation
mais ce que je dis aussi c'est qu'il ya
une question d'évaluation et qui est
excessivement compliqué puisqu'il n'ya
pas de traçabilité
donc on en revient à la question de la
traçabilité et je suis tout à fait je
remarque comme vous et c'est bien pour
ça que je les dis que ça fait dix ans
ces problèmes et soulever et disant
qu'il n'y a pas de solution je repense
que c'est la question de
l'expérimentation qui permettrait de
savoir quelle est la meilleure solution
pauline je te laisse continuer pauline
caby sur la question des contrôles
d'identité oui sur les contrôles
d'identité et plus plus précisément
puisque ça a été évoqué à l'occasion de
plusieurs de vos questions sur les sur
les contrôles d'identité
discriminatoires et l'intervention du
défenseur des droits devant le tribunal
judiciaire de paris dont il est rendu
compte dans le rapport annuel
je voudrais quand même dire de manière
très précise et très claire que ce ne
sont pas ce sont des interventions ce ne
sont pas
qui se font sous forme c'est prévu par
la loi organique sous forme de mix qui
rit curiae donc pour éclairer le
tribunal est donc ce ne sont pas des
dénonciations
ces interventions qui sont au soutien de
deux centres de soutien des partis mais
qui viennent tenter d'éclairer la
juridiction sur les problèmes juridiques
posés et d'apporter des réponses
un éclairage en tout cas se font sur une
analyse juridique exclusivement
juridique par des juristes très
compétent je dois le dire et le fait que
ainsi que nous en rendons compte qu'il
n'y ait pas le tribunal à ce stade donc
en première instance n'est pas suivi
l'analyse juridique proposé ne me paraît
pas pouvoir la décrédibiliser pour
autant ce d'autant qu'il y appelle que
le débat se poursuit et que quand bien
même au final dans cette analyse ne
serait pas suivie in fine et c'est cette
une analyse je le répète qui est
vraiment purement juridique et qui
cherche à faire avancer le débat
deuxième point sur sept sur sept sur
cette affaire dont nous rendons compte
et oui les questions de discrimination
systémique sont c'est un terme employé à
propos de cette affaire précisément donc
d'un cas particulier d'un cas unique et
ça n'est absolument pas la dénonciation
quelconque et généralisé généralisable
de discrimination systémique dans la
police n'est absolument pas le sens de
cette intervention devant le tribunal et
et de 2,7 de cette formule
et puis par ailleurs redire
effectivement l'attachement et le sens
de la mission du défenseur des droits
s'agissant de la déontologie domaine de
la sécurité il s'agit de renforcer
d'améliorer la relation police
population ce qui est une façon aussi de
marquer d'une part la mission et le
devoir du défenseur des droits dans la
dans la protection dans la défense des
droits des personnes s'estimant victime
de
de mauvais comportements ou de
manquements des forces de sécurité à
leur endroit
mais aussi d'assurer les missions de
sécurité des forces de l'ordre et nous y
sommes très sensibles et c'est ainsi
c'est ainsi que nous nous marquons notre
soutien par cette volonté qui est dans
l'intérêt de tout le monde et à
commencer par la démocratie de
d'améliorer la relation police
population sur les 122 observations que
nous avons pu faire devant les tribunaux
nous avons été suivis dans deux tiers
des cas donc sur les 122 observations
devant les tribunaux surtout thème tous
thèmes confondus sur nos cinq missions
qui sont au sein du défenseur des droits
donc juste important de de le redire sur
votre question madame sur les enfants de
la zone et sur le fait que certains sont
victimes aussi d'atteintes aux droits
fondamentaux je suis comme vous
particulièrement sensibles à cette
question là c'est pas pour rien que j'ai
eu envie d'avoir éric delamarre à mes
côtés puisque un profil éducateurs
directeur de centre qui a travaillé au
sein de la zone est dans la façon dont
on peut faire bouger de nombreuses
personnes font un travail remarquable au
sein de la zone il s'agit pas de jeter
l'opprobe mais il ya effectivement des
difficultés et je suis comme vous très
sensible à cette question et à voir
comment on peut avancer c'est vraiment
pour ça que j'ai voulu avoir éric
delamarre à mes côtés peut-être que eric
tu peux continuer à répondre sur ces
questions là oui merci madame la
sénatrice genou je ne peux que nous
pouvons que partager votre inquiétude
sur les enjeux autour de la protection
de l'enfance concernant ces difficultés
que vous avez rappelé très justement sur
le vivre ensemble
mais je dois vous dire que cette
question du vivre ensemble elles
existent indépendamment de la question
des mineurs non-accompagnés lorsque des
établissements doivent gérer des enfants
et du vivre ensemble des enfants en
situation de handicap des enfants qui
ont malheureusement qui peuvent être
protégées mais qui ont commis des délits
et des enfants victimes de ces délits la
question du vivre ensemble
elle est compliquée
les mineurs non-accompagnés peuvent bien
entendu arrive dans ces établissements
mais celle de la résumer uniquement à
leur situation il ya leurs origines me
pose question je crois qu'il faut
absolument réfléchir en matière de
moyens et de gouvernants sur les liens
entre protection de l'enfance et
pédopsychiatrie protection de l'enfance
et mdph le champ du médico-social et
pédopsychiatrie et pardon protection de
l'enfance et protection judiciaire de la
jeunesse en fonction des territoires il
n'ya plus d'établissements de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse il
n'y a plus de pédopsychiatres et quand
il y en a parfois c'est uniquement en
ambulatoire c'est pas en hospitalisation
et qu'effectivement les équipes de
d'établissement de protection de
l'enfance du secteur associatif et des
foyers de l'enfance font un travail
majoritairement formidable ils l'ont
montré pendant la crise qu vide et ils
ont aussi dès le 17 mars
accueillis au titre de l'urgence des
enfants sans masque 100 ans en sang sans
précaution et et je crois que c'est
vraiment dans ces partenariats très fort
en que que nous se trouveront la
solution et ce n'est pas de mon point de
vue en stigmatisant telle ou telle
population
moi j'en ai une
fonceur sûr vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le bilan de 2020 sur la
situation d'un lieu de détention l'a dit
le fait d'avoir démasqué enfin tout ce
qui est utile à la lutte contre le colis
de 19 quand les titres de la situerait
donc j'imagine que c'était la première
période entre les gares de confinement
peut être la deuxième mais quand l'été
de la situation actuelle alors là dessus
effectivement sur la disposition masque
gel nous avons moins de réclamations
les réclamations sont plutôt sur les
mines sur les jeunes qui sont incarcérés
l'accès à l'éducation l'accès à la
formation qui reste encore difficile
l'accès au travail et on sait comment
c'est à quel point c'est un facteur de
réinsertion à la sortie des lieux de
détention et on est encore alerté sur
c'est sur ces questions là entre autres
entre autres via nos délégués
et s'il n'y a pas d'autres questions
madame boyer ou à d'autres questions
je comprends vos réponses mais je vous
avoue que je suis un petit peu déçu du
contenu d'abord il s'agit pas de
stigmatiser mais poser des questions ce
terme valises je le trouve
particulièrement fatigant et pas du tout
ne fait pas avancer les choses
en revanche ces situations elles elles
doivent être traitées et aujourd'hui
c'est pas le cas donc c'est pour ça que
je posais la question vous m'avez
répondu mais j'ai pas eu ma réponse
de la même façon que la question de mon
collègue jean pierre sueur non plus je
n'ai pas entendu la réponse en tout cas
je n'ai pas compris votre réponse sur le
fait que malgré des situations très
graves qui auraient été exposés je suis
désolé je dois pas avoir un qi
nécessaire mais je n'ai absolument rien
compris à votre réponse donc j'aurais
bien aimé la voir vous reparler la des
mineurs non accompagnés de neuf sur lui
neuf je continue à vous répondre ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai répondu tout à l'heure
il est inadmissible que des réunions non
mixtes soit organisée c'est
effectivement de la discrimination je
vous le redis ray sur les mineurs non
accompagnés je vous redis je
excusez moi je ne suis pas en charge de
la politique publique
je suis en charge de la défense des
droits de la défense des droits des
enfants c'est ça que je viens vous dire
je ne suis pas en charge vous le redis
des politiques publiques
donc moi je vous dis qu'elles sont les
atteintes aux droits j'ai
particulièrement conscience que c'est
excessivement difficile comme situation
il n'y a pas de six il y avait une
solution très simple elle aurait déjà
été appliquée mon rôle
il est de rappeler les droits et vous
permettez puisqu'on en est à la
conclusion que vous redire ce que je
vous ai dit dans la présentation de ce
de ce rapport deux tiers des
réclamations que nous recevons deux
tiers des réclamations que nous recevons
sont des difficultés d'accès aux
services publics des difficultés que
rencontrent les usagers dans l'accès aux
services publics
c'est quelque chose qui m'inquiète je
pense que vous aussi vous êtes sensible
à ces questions en étant très implantée
sur les territoires et vous voyez
justement les personnes en difficulté
d'accès aux services publics et ces
difficultés sont aussi bien des
personnes qui au moment où elles font
valoir leur retraite ont des difficultés
pour le calcul du montant de leur
pension peuvent attendre plusieurs mois
quand c'est pas plus d'une année avant
de bénéficier de leur pension ce sont
des personnes qui sont en difficulté
quand elles font changer leur carte
grise et qu'elles n'ont pas de réponse
quand elles sont fait des stages pour
récupérer leurs points et où leurs
dossiers de permis de conduire n'avance
pas à la préfecture ce sont des
personnes en difficulté d'accès pour les
apl ou pour des ou pour des minima
sociaux
je suis inquiète de cette difficulté
d'accès aux services publics dans les
zones rurales de l'éloignement des
services publics
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
vous préoccupe aussi je vous redis deux
tiers de nos réclamations sont sur cette
question là et c'est ça aussi dont je
pense qu'il faut que nous parlions et
sur lequel nous pourrions avancer avec
le défenseur était saisie ou êtes-vous
saisine suffisamment régulièrement sur
les questions d'accès par voie numérique
et wind à toute la difficulté oui on est
bien de la possibilité pour un certain
nombre de nos concitoyens dans un moment
où tout est numérisé tous les services
publics notamment se trouve dans les
lycées c'est une la numérisation des
démarches de service public sont une
chance pour un grand nombre parce que ça
simplifie le fait de les fermes il ya
une partie de la population qui est en
grande difficulté d'accès aux services
publics
à cause de cette numérisation que ce
soit des personnes parce qu'ils sont en
difficultés pour remplir un dossier sur
internet des personnes qui n'ont pas un
accès à internet des gens qui sont
encore dans des zones où le réseau
internet n'est pas bon moi je continue à
dire que en vieillissant nos facultés
cognitives peuvent aussi baissé on
peut pas être forcément aussi habile sur
sur internet on l'a vue sur la campagne
de vaccination sur d'octo libre pour les
personnes âgées se sont beaucoup les
enfants qui ont fait les démarches pour
l'heure pour leurs parents âgés
je mon prédécesseur l'avait dit un
rapport avait été rendu sur cette
question de la dématérialisation il est
indispensable qu'une présence physique
dans nos services publics soit maintenu
une présence aussi téléphonique
c'est la seule solution pour garantir un
accès réel aux services publics
je pense qu'il va être intéressant de
voir ce qui se passe sur le
développement des maisons france service
certains de nos délégués vont être
présents dans ces maisons france et le
sont déjà dans ces maisons france
services et et de voir si effectivement
on arrive du coup à rapprocher l'usagé
du service public par ce biais là mais
mais je vois là je voulais insister là
dessus parce que je voulais que vous
ayez conscience du nombre de saisines
qu'on a là dessus de notre idée qu'on
voudrait trouver des solutions sur la
dématérialisation mon prédécesseur a
fait un rapport nous espérons d'ici la
fin de l'année
faire un suivi de ce rapport et c'est
quelque chose que je souhaite que nous
fassions c'est un suivi de nos rapports
c'est dans les préconisations qu'on a pu
faire qu'est-ce qui a réussi à être
appliquées qu est-ce qu il n'a pas été
pourquoi ça peut être intéressant et en
dialogue avec les services publics parce
que certains services publics ont des
idées pour résoudre pour résoudre ce
problème là et et voilà donc c'est
vraiment une de nos préoccupations je
vous tiendrai au courant de l'évolution
de ce rapport sur le suivi de la
dématérialisation
mais nous sommes inquiets de ce qui se
passe oui la dernière question c'est ma
dernière
non c'est plus une remarque parce que
c'est vrai que c'était très intéressant
d'avoir cette diction et je vous
remercie
mais je suis un petit peu resté sur ma
faim et à vous avouer madame madame et
monsieur ma déception parce que j'aurais
bien aimé comprendre comment fonctionne
le parallélisme des formes et là je n'ai
pas compris par rapport aux questions
que nous avons posées
alors dites moi si je me trompe pas pour
la discrimination vu par le
une conseil d'état je sais plus pour les
discriminations concernant les contrôles
au faciès excusez moi la journée longue
vous avez affiché votre position pas de
problème pour concernant celle de l'unef
mais on pourra trouver d'autres exemples
je n'ai pas compris vous avez rappelé le
droit bien évidemment on sait très bien
que les réunions non mixtes sont
interdites etc
dont acte mais qu'elles sont des actions
derrière pourquoi pourquoi on ne vous a
pas entendu sur cette question c'est
simplement ça qu'on aime enfin que
j'aimerais avoir je vois mon collègue
qui acquiesce la question de monsieur
sûr c'est ça que j'aurais aimé avoir
comme réponse officielle au moins pape a
prononcé le mot on a compté aussi sous
le nom de l'être s'il vous plaît je
pense je pense pouvoir dire sans être
démenti que les déclarations et les
réponses cause importé notamment la
dernière constitue une déclaration
publique puisque cette réunion de
commission a un caractère public
puisqu'elle est rendu public et diffusé
à la télévision et que chacun peut en
prendre connaissance et qu'on peut à la
valeur publique enfin je crois sans être
remise en cause pouvoir le dire sans
difficulté nous ne sommes pas en chambre
à huis clos et sans communication et
déclaration était son public tout à
chacun un nom sénateur a pu regarder sur
le site internet y compris les
journalistes votre audition et entendre
les propos que vous avez tenus après les
choses sont de ce point de vue là me
semble-t-il au moins sur ce plan
parfaitement public
[Musique]